I think one of the things I want to say
from the start is it's not like AI is
going to appear. It's actually out there,
in some instances in ways that we never
even notice. So for example checking
credit card usage, predicting
patients who are likely to come back
into the emergency room and therefore keeping them from going home and
then having to come back. There are some
very clever uses of artificial
intelligence in education. But
increasingly in ways in which we do
notice it. For example the various
personal assistants on our phones.
So it's out there making a difference
in most cases in situations where it's
not replacing people but really
working with people. So I stress that
distinction between replacing people and
complementing people because so much of
the science-fiction that's out there and
so much that's in the press presumes
that the goal would be to replace people.
But there's a perfectly wonderful way to
replace human intelligence. It takes
a man and a woman certain acts and
you're done and human intelligence is
limited in certain ways so why make that
the aim. I mean it has fascinated people for
centuries. Probably tied back to religion
and people being
concerned that people would try to
imitate God. This is the story
of The Golem it's the story of
Frankenstein it's the story of ex
machina. But that's not the best way to
think about developing
artificial intelligence methods nor
embodying them in computer systems.
Rather it would be better to complement
people as many computer systems do
now. So that's the reason I make that
distinction and urge it is that
regardless of which two aims you pick the
systems are going to- unless we
just send them to Mars by themselves -
they're going to exist in a world that's
populated with human beings. You can see
this playing out actually in something
that's been in the press a lot recently
which is autonomous and semi-autonomous
vehicles. So for example autonomous
vehicles the idea is they just drive.
No person's involved in the driving at all.
Semi autonomous vehicles do some driving
but then shift off with people. In both
cases they're interacting with people. So until we build roads on which the only vehicles are
fully autonomous the vehicles are going
to have to interact with people. And even
if the only vehicles are fully
autonomous we have to get rid of all of
the pedestrians and all of the bicycles
and everything. That's the issue with
fully autonomous they will still have to
interact with people.
Semi autonomous vehicles have to take
into account people's cognitive
capacities in order to handle the
so-called handoff between people and
computer systems appropriately. So
there's no, except in a few instances,
there's no taking people out of the
picture. I think it's a much more
valuable in societally useful
perspective to think from the very
beginning of designing in ways to
interact appropriately with people
rather than building something separate
from people and then presuming people
will adjust to it.
What's crucial at this point is to bring
together expertise from these different
fields and that that expertise has to be
brought in before the systems are
designed and released to the world. And
now is the time to think about this. To bring together people who
are experts in artificial intelligence
with people who understand ethics deeply with psychologists who understand
human cognition, with social scientists
who understand social organizations, so
that we can as the rubric now is "make AI
for social good." And that rubric
actually covers also building systems
that help low-resource communities,
building systems that protect the
environment, building systems that contribute to education and
healthcare. I think both that we need to
train and teach people about ethics.
And here I want to say I'm not talking
about professional ethics. I'm talking
about really understanding the
trade-offs between consequentialist ideas
and deontological ideas, grappling
with virtue ethics, thinking about
justice, thinking about who you're serving, really
a deep sense of ethics and about these
systems, and then make it part of the
process of design of the systems. It's a
years-long process of having people from
these different fields come together,
explain their work, explain their
perspectives to each other in ways that
are accessible, treat those different
perspectives with respect, and develop a
common vocabulary and a
way of approaching things
together. That can't be
short-circuited it's really a years-long process.